[Applause]
the last debate ahead of the general
election next Sunday Sergio Masa who is
now Argentina's economy Minister and
farri libertarian Javier M squared off
at the University of
woid M has promised to shut down the
central bank to fight skyrocketing
inflation and dollarize the economy for
many an Argentinian version of Donald
Trump he attacked Masa on his inability
to control the over 11% inflation rate a
month and accused him of being part of a
political case that has ruined
Argentina do you know what your problem
is that you blew up our income with you
as minister of economy income fell by
33% which had already been falling
before
Mar Masa has the support of the powerful
peronist party labor unions and he
promises to fix the country's endemic
economic troubles he says melee is a
threat to democracy and will only
deteriorate even further Argentina's
economic
situation what we're seeing is someone
who out of ideological Prejudice has put
his own interests above those of
Argentina and on December the 10th sits
in Riva davia's armchair and has to stop
thinking about himself and his ideology
and think about
Argentina if latest polls are right
Javier M has managed to recover from the
defeat on the first round of the
election and has now narrow lead over
economy Minister Serio Masa elections
are just a week away argentinians are in
the middle of an economic crisis and
people are filled with uncertainty about
who is going to lead this country in the
next four years there is aljas
buis